Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192 to David P. Here's a caller
who's glad we were banned from Tik Tok.
Speaker 3: I'm. I'm glad you were banned
from TikTok because you're my life.
Speaker 1: Oh, well, that's really sad.
I think the caller will be saddened to hear that
we are back on TikTok. So last week I talked about
being banned from TikTok, which is increasingly a
great platform for us to be reaching young people,
young voters. Here's how it all went down over
the weekend. We were originally banned from
TikTok for COVID and election disinformation.
We appealed it. We were then told, no, you're
going to continue being banned for violating
the nudity policy. Now, I can assure you.
We did not post any nudity. I didn't post nude
pictures of myself. There were no nude pictures
of Trump posted. There was no nudity on our
account whatsoever. We again appealed that.
And hundreds of you wrote in to Tik Tok Legal,
which I very much appreciate. Without explanation,
the account was reinstated. We don't know
why. Days later, Tik Tok responded and said,
We've reversed the decision. Your account has been
reinstated. We still know very little about what
happened, but much to this caller's dismay, we
are back on Tik Tok. We have a great bonus show
for you today. Kanye West is apparently in talks
to buy the social media platform. Parler. I know
you probably forgot about Parler. We will talk
about it. A court has rejected an appeal to give
American Samoans U.S. citizenship. We will talk
about the basis for that decision. And lastly,
more and more American companies are
charging employees for job training if
they quit before a certain amount of time has
gone by. Is it legal? Yeah, it appears to be,
as long as it's done in a certain way. Is it
ethical? Well, that's a different question.
All of those stories and more on today's
bonus show. Sign up at. Join Pacman icon.